Well,
even the extravagant
spending proposals,
which is what I'm calling for it,
we're talking about on the order of four
percent of GDP now,
we have debt.
I should check that number.
I believe we have a debt GDP ratio and
then 50 percent ish range right now.
That's not good.
It's been rising in,
in,
in the absence of a major war,
which is not supposed to happen,
but I look at other advanced countries
they've managed to have or ourselves.
We had a debt to GDP ratio of 125
percent at the end of World War Two and
paid it down and never.
There was never a question about the
good faith and credit of the US
government.
Even advanced countries with fairly weak
governments,
uh,
Belgium,
Italy have managed to have a debt debt
equal to or greater than GDP.
So we have a lot of running room as long
as there's a reasonable presumption that
we will in the end,
do what's necessary to bring our
finances under control.
It's not that we can't afford to spend
this much.
Um,
it's and,
and the,
the alternative not,
not providing the stimulus is just to
run the risk of a truly frightening.